previously on devour
anna puerta leader of demonic local cult
has not been seen for weeks i'm just
eroding damn looks we have no we don't
have time to explain it anna needs our
help to die
who uses an abacus oh god no
hey sam i just wander through hey i
found flowers
i found anna yeah
we haven't heard we haven't heard that
good fight we haven't heard wade in a
while
we haven't heard wade in a while oh god
my god
oh my god i'm right here dude
what what did we tell you about skulking
around
yeah you gotta stop skulking man god
anyway uh well this is apparently the
gamer lounge that's pretty cool
yeah yeah that's for nerds you more like
it see um
what's up what you can't do that too man
you can't do that too it's just dana oh
hey hey anna i'm just gonna close that
well that didn't work all right we'll
see you around bob i'm
upstairs i'm just gonna go outside on my
own see ya
she won't come out here will she well i
don't know i guess we'll see
i'm going to just go around to the front
door flower
i found that all right good job man uh
if wait if you had to guess what the
flowers are for i'm not saying you know
i'm just saying if you had to guess
where was the flower that i found just
uh it was up uh up on the upstairs way
in one of the doors uh right right yeah
i found that one wait what the
how did you
oh it loops okay all right i th okay bob
no i'm very much the magician
okay all right
i didn't know i didn't mean to scare you
twice but now you're even suspicious of
me for walking through two different
doors
yeah yeah so you said you got more keys
what are the keys to go to
i don't remember oh hey on the by the
bed does it go oh
goat how do i burn it
it's scared of me i can't grab it maybe
we got to lead it somewhere with like
hate no we need a master bathroom key
you've mastered
that i have master bedroom key and attic
key i remember
exactly what keys i have i just didn't
before you could also press k to look
but okay
i will never look another upstairs
key an upper stick master bathroom i got
it oh
sick that's your bathroom
wow i really want to know oh goat oh
guys hole oh ho
hey we've got goats trapped in here what
do we do pour gas on the ground hey hey
hey wait a minute everybody come here to
the sink
yo what's up there are two toothbrushes
on this thing
oh [ __ ] you guys know anna was dating oh
my god
do you think it's first i thought one of
the cult rules was no dating
i mean yeah i adhere to that rule
i found a flower by the way nice find
man yeah no no dating
no dating man we all know the rule
i feel like i'm the only one who follows
any of the rules we all know the rule
well i mean dating's a very general term
yeah yeah you know no it means something
that is clearly defined
dating is emotional connections i only
crave physical
i literally only crave the physical but
what if you like only
date what if you're not aren't dating
you know like what if you date singular
dating is going on a date dude yeah
selfish [ __ ] who has all the keys do
we have a play room
key or a guest bedroom god no no not at
all no no no i don't know what do we
have
i don't remember i remember exactly what
keys i have i just didn't before
oh creepy rocking chair we have that oh
it rocks on its own that's pretty neat
that's pretty neat
yeah pretty cool guest bedroom key
hmm it's a big house i just have to say
that
this is too much house for anna uh bob
is thinking all this i think you forgot
i have a funny feeling there's something
else in this room but you know i might
be mistaken oh yeah there's totally a
flower that i found in the room uh
guys it is over here just come grab it
cool you see it
yeah i see it yeah i see it yeah i see
it i found that flower
okay cool yeah good job man
so anyway we go up huh yeah this is
where we were about before we go
when we tried to not talk to anna nice
ass
thanks hey look at this yeah i got a key
hey nice man nice it doesn't say
what kind it is basement what i
had the basement key that's weird hey
wow is this anna
nice does it go to the other door in the
basement maybe instead of the one we
[Music]
opened
oh dude get the goats out
nice oh okay i feel like
if we're supposed to burn the goats
couldn't we have burned them in the cage
is that just unsporting it's
anyway i found the uh guest bedroom key
oh go we supposed to be doing something
with these ghosts i feel like we're
forgetting something so like it starts
with an f
it's like feed supposed to feed them
feed the goats
feed the goats i think feel them feel
them
i don't i don't think feel no play room
key we found playroom
find fine thanks
no find them like like a money fine
charge them yeah yeah has anyone seen
anna in a hot minute i feel like she was
kind of hanging around and
well you know she's you know antisocial
oh wait i found another key
cool also i know that we worship a goat
demon
but does anna really have to have
pictures of goats everywhere
actual regular goats well you know
there's theming and then there's too far
well you know
kind of cult's whole thing is going a
little too far so who are we the judge
what are you wade where are you what key
did you find
here's my knees playroom i opened the
play room oh cool oh okay
cool stuff in there i thought there's a
flower i found cool stuff
cool all i did was open up and a goat
ran out all right yeah yeah i found a
flower guys
nice nice nice nice nice
good find ah
hey uh man this bed is dirty i don't
know what happened here
something's clicking some kind of
clicking going on in here
ah it's you sick man anyway look at this
bed
oh no poopy's in the bed no yeah
some poopies in the bed isn't always
somebody made poopies in the bed hey i
found a flower guys nice good fine
good also somebody literally took the
drawer boys
yeah what's up come across the hall okay
is there a flower right there under the
bed it's definitely not man
uh no i don't see one i'm the one who
finds the flowers so
yeah nice trouble but you know whatever
that's fair that's fair sorry
yeah well you should be bob can you come
look under this bed
i'm not even gonna look i don't believe
you
oh no i found a flower mark oh cool man
i knew it would be there good eye
good eye good eye man oh man i just
remembered i gotta run downstairs bob
can you come with me i'm scared to go on
my own
um wait you could come too i guess but
man i am
super super super oh you definitely
don't want to go
oh man i went oh hey look i found a
flower guys oh wow cool
good job oh man thank you so much
yeah yeah yeah what are we well we got
we got one more key
you got one more key right bob the
basement no i don't think i had the
basement key i don't think yeah
do you use the keys up when you when you
do stuff
no i got them in my my inventory did we
go
to the attic we did the attic right yeah
we were in the attic we were in the
attic
oh hey anna there you are jesus anna
somewhere
she's up here she's up here we still
have
at least a key or two to find but yeah
uh you know it could be a good idea to
try feeding the goats
okay cool man goats are probably hungry
yeah i bet they are
what do we what did goats eat man i
don't know man i don't know
gasoline uh gasoline or key
yeah oh hey
oh come back
come back here mike i found flower
oh sick man good job man
21 flowers that's pretty good
oh what so what do you what do you eat
hey
oh huh burn it i got it
oh my god i have it what do you what do
you need to burn it gasoline
well okay so if i had to guess if i had
to guess
there's like a pit in the backyard right
without
so maybe you know maybe maybe we put a
goat in there and
see what happens you know oh
wow um well there's a
demon thing okay it wasn't really a
problem okay
yeah well i just didn't like my
flashlight
okay papa get pop her in wow
[Music]
yeah it's gonna turn my flashlight off
oh man okay we should definitely
investigate it
yeah i'll look is it anna she in pain
maybe she tripped and stubbed her toe or
something maybe man sounded like a toe
stub
classic toe stub
oh
all right you got it man you got it dog
help
you got it man help yeah all right
biggest preacher i got another goat huh
goat in the bowl guys i'm out of purple
guys goat in the bowl go to the ball
okay good good i'm sure nothing bad will
happen now goat in the bowl
i'm gonna close some of these doors why
would you do that
because i don't know maybe that's a bad
idea
oh man we're really burning through
those goats now yeah man
oh wow that doesn't sound good at all
she sounds upset i gotta be honest very
uh likely not happy yeah that's not
not what i would call good oh my god
hello hey hey dude hey what's up man hey
how do you go
how do you get the goat what do you do
you put the hay down and they love hay
and then you grab them
how do you put the hay down gee you put
it you drop it yeah
i see so it's like oh well that's oh
i'm purpling as much oh i'm about to run
out of purple i'm about to
i'm round or right i'm out of purple
aura
are you upstairs no well now i'm not
there's demons there's a couple demons a
couple ha ha
yeah wade oh
god hey let's burn another goat ah good
job man i'm getting demon
there's no more gasoline at the fire no
gasoline well that's a problem
what if we can can we optimize our gas
usage
i've ever heard very loud rain oh my god
the rain is coming down ow who the hell
biting my ankles [ __ ] jesus
christ that's so loud bobby okay
no hell oh you're down i'm coming
oh god there's little crawly dudes
everywhere
yeah the little demons oh i can crawl
oh she's right by me i'm coming in the
attic hey
what's up i'll go up those stairs yeah
yeah yeah those doors bad stairs okay
closing that door
oh she's not happy i don't know why
she's
unhappy wait i'm crawling down the the
other hey go ahead buddy help me okay
yeah you know what
i got it i got you there you go man
thank you you're welcome man you're
welcome oh look out
oh there's a demon guy out here right
now i ran out of purple i ran out of
power
jesus christ wade what the hell
oh wait this is not talking and then
comes back in oh
wow wow hey wade it's okay
i ran out of flashlights i'll be back
guys i'm out of flashlight as well
i have flashlight i need to get some
more goats i guess
yeah we do wait you're all right he's
not
so hot yeah she is by him
okay okay got these guys down bunch of
chumps i need some hay
that's what i need yeah hey man i see
some downstairs you can actually see
them
you can see them when you're down are
there any over here
whoops oh damn it i wasted a gasoline
guys
no goat burn i was dumb i thought i had
a goat
did not no goat guys we're about twenty
oh i think that's it right there
mark we're dealing with stuff right all
right cool man good job man
okay well we have to get we got lots of
gasoline don't worry about that
what's that what's happening mark
yeah what's up what's up yeah i'm fine
little ankle biter but it's okay uh anna
doesn't sound very happy oh she's here
dude that's just she's
she's mad she's mad oh she's mad
[ __ ] god that's so loud i'll get you
in a second man
okay i'm down i'll be right there whoa
hey
dudes you dudes kind of suck oh anna is
out here oh you went down out here
outside guys oh yeah you are oh yeah you
are here i'll come over here
i don't have a first aid there's yeah
he's got it he's got it
let's get out of here get out there
man that's loud i'm putting the goat in
okay no i had gas sorry
i had gas we need goats
well can i just jump in the fire myself
no
i'm gonna swing around and grab more she
targeted me i didn't do anything
that's fine man i'm gonna go around too
with anna just standing right there i
think the front yard
hey how's it going okay i'm gonna go
inside the house now
holy god hey goats
i got some yummy nummy grass for you hey
anna hey
what's up where's she at uh coming in
the back door
kind of slow burning a goat look out
don't be near anna what uh um
oh god hey goat you grabbing that goat
why am i flickering oh well don't worry
about it hey i'll be right behind you
with this goat all right we got two
goats
this is an ankle biter stairs
oh holy [ __ ] oh man
she's right there yeah she's right there
nowhere near us nowhere near
she was there man she was there oh
baby oh god i'm out of purple god damn
it i'm getting regular old demon killed
wade where have you been where have i
been i was looking for ghosts i had hay
in my hand
i i had a goat in my hand yeah a goat is
a little more important than your health
dude i got a first aid kit i'm going for
mark wait over here over here
watch out she's right behind me well be
careful
thanks thank you man thank you hey ankle
biter demon man
all right i'm fun purple
i'm full purple ready to blur
that's not good what is that what is she
yelling about
i don't know man she's she's just you
know
she's whatever she's whatever she's just
anna she's just
my mom locked in a dining room by myself
with only one door and i'm pretty sure
she's right outside of it
hello oh god
man come on is she now it's so bad
i'm sorry but now god damn
let's just close that yeah close that
what is the fire sound
uh the flames of justice uh
there's some hay also in the front door
area there's like
two ghosts open this door in front of me
i'm outside i'm outside close it just
close it back
where's that bathroom wow she's coming
out the front
bob
yeah she's going somber she's going oh
she's timid she's calm
she's a little [ __ ] chilling out she's
filling out all right i'm gonna get this
goat we're gonna burn it
oh yeah getting goat on the run i'm
gonna
leave all right guys i'm going back to
the car i'm gonna wait in the car
yeah it's a good idea man it's a good
idea we're almost done you guys finished
up yeah we got it here comes the slime
boom seven
alright win ah
he's gone quiet it's a good sign
i'm gonna go to the basement are there
ghosts in the basement no no can you
come to the attic instead
that's really far from the pace never
mind
do not come up here there's nothing but
her and demon monsters everywhere i'm
crawling down all right i think we got
enough gas we got three gas tanks we
need three more goats
all right i'm grabbing a medkit i'm
coming to find you where's anna
oh hey
okay got hmm one down oh she's mad i'm
angry
okay bob how much purple you got
okay we'll get yeah we can get it we can
get this we can get this when she comes
we're gonna blast her we're gonna buzz
her she in here where is she
because if she's not in here i'm going
to get this little goat yeah get that
goat you just buy me
main floor she's main floor she coming
okay she's coming
i'm going to snatch the goat i don't see
her let's go do the coat let's go
you go do the goat you go do the goat
i'm going to see if i got a window to
get weighed
she'll probably be real mad at me when i
do this
yeah probably oh wait are you clear are
you clear are you clear
there's a there's a crawly okay i don't
see her right now
wow what the hell oh god that was me
oh that's that's i'm gonna close this
door uh okay i'm getting getting weighed
up getting weight up getting weight up
getting weight up
okay we're good we're good oh uh oh uh
oh all right bob i'm coming to you we're
gonna
we're gonna blaster okay we're gonna
blaster i'm gonna no i'm going around
the front
never mind teamwork
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sorry what about teamwork
she uh she got me wait you were running
away from her
she's in the front she's in the front of
the house she's in the front of the
house yeah yeah she carried me here
wait did you you were running from her
and you didn't tell me
no bosses in the front i was running
around to get the bomb you were
literally
all right we just gotta get two more
goats
oh she's she's getting pissed you
shouldn't have announced our intentions
i just gotta be honest we're just gonna
slam dunk two goats that's it we're done
so yeah we should get two goats at the
same time
yeah definitely just rush out there
and burn burn burn baby burn yeah burn
baby burn
burn baby burn baby be burning
any idea where the last two goats are
are there only ten
think so what is that what's the oh
she's on me i'm purple
i'm out of trouble she's like i'm coming
to you i'm coming
i'm on the main floor in the in the main
entrance way uh purple did not slow her
down very much
yeah where are you i've got one of the
final two goats
oh there she's in the backyard yeah i'm
out the back i'm out the back
i don't have a first aid kit but i'm
gonna look for one got one right here oh
let me come to you let me come in
however right now right here's good
[Music]
the other one i'm gonna go to the
basement i've got a goat in hand okay
she's mad is she mad i'm gonna try and
find the last coat here i'm gonna go to
the basement
looking for a basement oh yeah we came
in the basement yeah
she's cruising thankfully not cruising
this way anyone know where she's
cruising
she's outside in the side yard i just
ran face first into her
did she get yucky nope nope i stunned
her in time
good good good call good call you need
help
i'm gonna guess the lack of answer is a
no front door
lost to go to the front door lost to go
all right i'm gonna go i'm gonna go for
the goat
i'm gonna go for the goat i got the goat
go
ah ankle bottom got that goat i got to
i'm not gonna burn that goat yet until
we get the next goat ready lined up
because we got two gas
i closed myself inside with her that's
not what
yes you said inside with you
you said that i yeah well she changed
her mind i think
she
door i'm going to go in the back door
wait she's upstairs right now get
weighed
getting weighed right now i'm looking
around this uh the attic for
uh a goat to see if like there's one
last one up here
yeah we need one more right yeah one's
already in the pile
we just need one more
oh guys i found a flower hey good job
man
well she's downstairs she's downstairs
she's swooping she's zooming she's got
dog zoomies
i'm hearing that go i'm hearing a goat
she got me again
wait did you hear that goat heard a goat
mark always do you see any first dates
mark
uh yeah i do i think i'm in a room with
one don't worry she's carrying me to
mark i'm gonna be real close
okay cool man i think i i think i see
one
uh it's uh in the like child's playroom
oh that's
upstairs right yeah yeah yeah but we're
both up here on this floor
yeah just be careful man
yeah it's somewhere around here should i
go for the goat should i just win it
if you can whatever you think is easiest
i've got the goat go
go go go go go go go go go close the
doors all the way out
oh my god it's gone
it's fine fine getting outside good good
good excellent please excellent
excellent yeah excellent yeah yeah
excellent
she's gonna be fine she's cruising is
she zooming me she's zooming she's
zooming you
i think she's she's pushing yarn
holy [ __ ] she's so
fast are we all dead or i got the second
goat in by the way
oh you did oh [ __ ] yeah so
good job guys gg hey yeah gg guys
gg man
god it's god
good work gang good work my assessment
of the entire game is
pretty fun too loud too loud
and it's pretty fun though pretty fun
though how did i understand what's
supposed to happen i feel like we could
definitely win that
yeah one of the better uh multiplayer
horror games of this style
definitely
you